por qué
a
el presidente de nicaragua daniel ortega
se enfrenta al repudio de buena parte de
la comunidad internacional con el 75 por
ciento de los votos obtuvo una cómoda
reelección sin embargo naciones como
rusia venezuela e irán respaldaron al
sandinista analizamos en esta edición
la oposición en bolivia comenzó un paro
indefinido contra el gobierno de luis
arce justo cuando el presidente cumple
su primer año en el poder arcedio su
informe de gestión ante la asamblea
legislativa en medio de abucheos
tendremos reportes desde la paz
crecen las tensiones en la frontera de
entre belarús y polonia cientos de
migrantes intentaron cruzar las barreras
de alambres de púas que dividen a los
dos países la comisión europea urgió más
sanciones contra el gobierno de
alexander lukachenko a quien acusan de
usar a los migrantes como un arma
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy [__] la calle y las acompañaré
en este recorrido
en medio de una controvertida elección
el presidente de nicaragua daniel ortega
fue reelegido para un cuarto mandato
consecutivo de cinco años de duración
varios países latinoamericanos la oea
eeuu y la unión europea rechazaron los
resultados de los comicios y es que
desde mayo fueron arrestado cerca de 40
opositores entre ellos 7 precandidatos
presidenciales pero países como rusia
irán y venezuela respaldaron a ortega
aurora valle nos explica las reacciones
con todos los potenciales rivales
encarcelados no hubo sorpresa en
nicaragua daniel ortega consiguió con
facilidad un cuarto mandato consecutivo
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden calificó los comicios como una
pantomima y anunció posibles nuevas
sanciones
las elecciones antidemocráticas de ayer
negaron al pueblo nicaragüense un voto
real el gobierno de ortega murillo
traicionó sus compromisos con la carta
democrática interamericana
la unión europea también señaló que la
reelección de ortega carecía de
legitimidad y adviertió que tampoco
descartaba adoptar nuevas restricciones
las voces de rechazo también se
escucharon en américa latina' el
presidente de colombia iván duque pidió
una reacción a más alto nivel del
continente colombia no reconocen las
elecciones en nicaragua ya hay posturas
de varios países que tampoco la
reconocen
entonces este tipo de decisiones tienen
que escalar se al consejo permanente de
la organización de estados américanos
desde la cancillería peruana aseguraron
que las elecciones no fueran justas y
libres ni transparentes mientras que las
autoridades chilenas y uruguayas
hicieron un llamado a la liberación sin
condiciones de los presos políticos del
régimen nicaragüense otros como el
gobierno de venezuela felicitaron a
ortega por una reelección que tiraron de
legítima e inobjetable el ex presidente
de bolivia evo morales se sumó a las
felicitaciones
saludamos al digno pueblo de nicaragua
que en una demostración de coraje y
madurez democrática eligió al hermano
daniel ortega como presidente
constitucional pese a la campaña de
mentiras chantaje y amenazas de eeuu el
triunfo de ortega es la derrota del
intervencionismo yanqui
finalmente cuba calificó las elecciones
como una demostración de soberanía y
civismo y rusia tachó de inaceptable el
rechazo de algunos países occidentales a
los resultados electorales de nicaragua
destacando la buena organización de la
jornada pasamos a bolivia donde la
oposición inició un paro indefinido
contra el gobierno de luis arcén ellos
afirman que una ley que aprobó la
mayoría lista de la asamblea legislativa
le permite a las autoridades intervenir
las cuentas bancarias esto coincide con
el primer año de luís arce en el poder
el mandatario presentó su informe de
gestión previamente nuestra corresponsal
en la paz mery vaca nos habló de las
tensiones que se viven tanto en la calle
como en el parlamento
bolivia ha vivido una jornada de tensión
tanto de las calles como en el parlament
o en las calles porque se ha cumplido el
primer día de paro cívico en contra del
gobierno de luís arce y en el parlamento
porque el mandatario tuvo que dar su
mensaje a la nación en ocasión de
cumplir el primer año de su gobierno en
las calles los sectores sociales han
intentado bloquear las calles sin
embargo el oficialismo se ha jugado el
todo por el todo para evitar la protesta
el gobierno ha desplazado policías a
todo el país y ha sacado a los sectores
sociales afines al movimiento al
socialismo para evitar los bloqueos esto
ha degenerado en enfrentamientos en
algunas ciudades del país como por
ejemplo santa cruz cochabamba y potosí
en el resto de los departamentos el paro
ha sido seguido de manera muy parcial e
incluso en la paz prácticamente no se ha
sentido el paro de estos sectores
sociales busca la derogatoria de una ley
en contra de la legitimación de
ganancias ilícitas
entretanto en el parlamento el
presidente luís ar se ha destacado los
avances de su gestión se ha comparado
con el gobierno transitorio de jeanine
áñez al que ha llamado reitera la mente
gobierno de facto arte por ejemplo ha
señalado que la economía ha empezado a
reactivarse que la pobreza se ha
reducido con el pago del bono contra el
hambre y también ha destacado los
avances en el control de la pandemia y
la vacunación sin embargo todos estos
mensajes no han sido escuchados por los
parlamentarios porque se ha producido
una caótica sesión en la que los
opositores gritaban fraude fraude y los
oficialistas luchó luchó e incluso hubo
uso de silbatos e intentos de
enfrentamiento entre los parlamentarios
que no dejaron escuchar el discurso del
mandatario en esta sesión
en noticias de eeuu las familias de los
jóvenes que murieron en la avalancha
humana en el festival musical astro
world en houston presentarán más
demandas aunque las autoridades ya
iniciaron una investigación criminal
para hallar las causas de la estampida
humana los familiares de las víctimas
piden que los promotores del evento sean
procesados por la justicia vídeos
muestran como le pedían al rapero travis
scott que frenara su presentación el
show continuó durante al menos 40
minutos más y al final 8 jóvenes entre
los 14 y los 27 años perdieron la vida
pues me siento devastado
por la pérdida de mi hijo
pero como dice el abogado
esperemos que
que su vida cambia las cosas
de cómo se hacen esos eventos porque el
vino
a tener
un rato agradable el propósito de eeuu
este país reabrió sus fronteras aéreas
para los vuelos que llegan de 27
naciones europeas es la primera vez que
esto ocurre desde marzo del 2020 cuando
el país clausuró los viajes
intercontinentales por la pandemia el
ingreso de viajeros cuenta con una serie
de requerimientos como tener el esquema
completo de vacunación de cualquiera de
los antídotos que reconoce la
organización mundial de la salud también
es requerida una prueba con resultado
negativo alva santana tiene la
información
20 meses después los europeos pueden
viajar de nuevo a eeuu con colas en
varios aeropuertos del continente son
muchos los que esperan con ansias
reunirse con sus amigos y familiares no
just volamos a houston para ver a
nuestro hijo al que no vemos desde hace
dos años
es emocionante porque las restricciones
tienen que cambiar la libre circulación
es necesaria y todas las restricciones
son contraproducentes limitan la
socialización de la gente mi mujer es
estadounidense yo soy alemán y estas
restricciones han afectado a nuestra
familia xd sus restricciones hijas de
familia no obstante las restricciones no
se han suprimido por completo para poder
viajar a eeuu los pasajeros por motivos
no esenciales deberán contar con la
pauta de vacunación completa y una
prueba pcr negativa realizada al menos
tres días antes al viaje un avance que
muchos gobiernos europeos celebran se
trata de volver a reunir a las familias
se trata de asegurar que vas a poder ver
a tu familia y amigos después de año
junto con reino unido a las fronteras de
los 26 países del espacio schengen e
irlanda permanecían cerradas desde marzo
de 2020 una decisión adoptada por la
administración de donald trump pero que
joe biden decidió mantener y que causó
enfado en la unión europea que permite
la entrada unidenses vacunados desde
comienzos de verano pero ahora con el 70
por ciento de su población adulta
vacunada completamente eeuu finalmente
avanza con su estrategia de reapertura a
continuación damos un vistazo a otras
noticias sobre el cob y 19 en juba más
de 600 12.000 estudiantes regresaron a
las clases presenciales para comenzar el
año lectivo 2020 2021 que fue
interrumpido como consecuencia de la
pandemia la mayoría de los estudiantes
recibieron el esquema completo de las
vacunas abdalá soberana 2 y soberana
plus desarrolladas en este país en
alemania la tasa de contagios por joven
19 rompió un nuevo récord al llegar a
los 201 casos por cada 100.000
habitantes según reportó el instituto
robert koch el centro nacional de
control de enfermedades las autoridades
han llamado a este repunte como en la
pandemia de los no vacunados
y rusia retomó las actividades tras una
semana no laboral decretada por las
autoridades del kremlin todo para frenar
el aumento de contagios de coronavirus
sin embargo el fin de semana el país
batió su récord diario de contagios al
registrar más de 41 mil nuevos casos en
tan solo 24 horas mientras que el récord
de decesos llegó a mil 195 fallecidos en
plena semana de vacaciones
y el ex presidente de eeuu barack obama
dijo desde la cob 26 que el mundo no ha
hecho lo suficiente para frenar el
calentamiento global el exmandatario uno
de los impulsores del acuerdo de parís
criticó que los presidentes de china y
rúsia no asistieran presencialmente a la
cumbre también le pidió a todas las
potencias que asuman su responsabilidad
en la contaminación del planeta estas
fueron sus palabras
[Aplausos]
y aún no estamos cerca de donde
necesitamos estar
desde el regreso muchos países han
fallado en aplicar los planes que se
establecieron hace seis años y las
consecuencias se están volviendo más
permanentes cada vez el mes pasado el
85% de la población global experimentó
aspectos climáticos más severos debido
al cambio climático tormentas más
fuertes olas de calor más largas
inundaciones más intensas partes del
mundo se están convirtiendo en lugares
más peligrosos para vivir en otras
noticias escaló la crisis fronteriza
entre belarús y polonia la presidenta de
la comisión europea úrsula von der leyen
presionó al bloque para que se aprueben
nuevas sanciones contra minsk y es que
cientos de migrantes intentaron cruzar
hacia polonia derribando las cercas de
alambres de púas desde bruselas acusan
al gobierno de belarús de utilizar la
migración irregular como arma política
previamente hablamos con nicolás de
pedro analista senior del institute for
state craft de londres él nos explicó
cuál es la situación de los migrantes
claro esta es la cuestión más compleja y
más problemática porque aquí lo que
tenemos es una población que ha sido
traída exprofeso desde irak en los
directos
hasta bielorrusia para llevarlo después
a la frontera para lanzarlo contra
lanzar a esta población contra las
fronteras de polonia evidentemente que
busca algún tipo de solución humanitaria
pero conviene poner que toda la presión
de la unión europea esté puesta sobre
minsk capital de bielorrusia y sobre
moscú que son quienes están orquestando
este movimiento y este ataque de
naturaleza híbrida si queremos contra la
unión europea porque si no
y básicamente lo que seguirá en lo que
se conseguirá es recompensar al agresor
y que sea un incentivo para que
bielorrusia siga utilizando a los
inmigrantes como arma contra polonia y
lituania obviamente están tratando de
explotar las actuales tensiones que hay
entre el gobierno polaco y la comisión
europea pero la comisión en este caso
debe ser muy clara y ponerse del lado de
el gobierno polaco para poder mitigar
esta situación y buscar una solución una
respuesta humanitaria a la crisis pero
poniendo toda la presión política sobre
minsk capital de bielorrusia que el
bloque apoye a polonia es lo que nos
dice el analista nicholas depedro él
también nos habló de los riesgos de que
escalen las tensiones y es que ahora los
polacos movilizaron más de 12.000
soldados a la frontera algo similar y
solitaria escuchemos lo que nos dijo
claro es que aquí el problema es que no
sé evidentemente esta población
inmigrante son las grandes víctimas son
son son víctimas desde todos los puntos
de vista pero están siendo
instrumentalizados por el gobierno
bielorruso y están siendo empujadas como
como arma para romper o asaltar la
frontera de polonia el riesgo de que se
produzca una escaramuza entre fuerzas
armadas o policiales de polonia o de
lituania con fuerzas policiales o
militares
bielorrusas bueno pues ese elevado
evidentemente porque lo que está
sufriendo es un asalto a su soberanía a
sus fronteras nacionales y eso
evidentemente puede
conducir a una escalada de tensiones
fronteriza y se cumplió el primer año
desde que azerbaiyán y armenia
terminaron su guerra por la región de
nagorno karabaj azerbaiyán hizo una
ceremonia oficial con la presencia de
militares y el presidente del país para
celebrar su triunfo por su parte de no
armenia los partidos de la oposición se
manifestaron en la capital y volvieron a
culpar al primer ministro
para chillán por la derrota durante los
44 días del enfrentamiento murieron más
de 3.700 soldados armenios y 2800
azerbaiyanos además más de 100.000
civiles fueron desplazados al final
rusia impulsó el acuerdo de paz
y con estas noticias termina nuestro
informativo pero esperen más información
de economía en minutos
[Música]